okay
you mentioned that on your recent
program on your recent podcast with
brett
that talking about free will in the
discourse discord
servers you said sometimes you log on
you see people talking about free will
and one other topic which i can't recall
but free will in particular is
unproductive why why do you say that
debating about free will is unproductive
well what i what i notice is that people
will have the same conversations over
and over again
and if i tune in on one or i tune in
another i've pretty much heard all of
the arguments that are being advanced
so i believe that you have to learn to
recognize the signature of people
trying to solve a misstated problem
trying to solve a problem where the
framework for solving that problem does
not yet exist
okay so it's not the problem itself it's
the framework
of the problem much like the problem
relative to the framework that we're in
where people will have a conversation
that'll go on for an hour before anyone
will ask the question do we even know
what we mean by free will
so i i just find these conversations are
not like
the conversations of um
you know another topic i want to get
people interested in
is that the haberman switch pitch
which is a toy bit based on the self
duality of the tetrahedron could you
build one
exhibiting the duality between the
dodecahedron and icosahedron that's a
very concrete
thing that could be done somebody could
actually build a physical implementation
of this idea
i'm positive that the free will
discussion is going to be going on two
weeks from now and it's going to sound
the same as the one this week
now i could be wrong maybe somebody in
some discord chat somewhere is gonna
and then i will have egg on my face but
i'm so unworried
and unconcerned about that i'm willing
to commit to you on this podcast that
20 years from now we're still going to
be having free will discussions if we
don't have a more profound theory of
physics